willkommen zu einem neuen sendung von
tilo krauß diesmal mit dr nahles armee
ferenc starterin
wir haben jetzt eine tagung über das
böse aus interdisziplinärer perspektive
wir hatten gesehen dass der philosophie
alleine den bösen nicht gerecht wird
wir brauchen verschiedene perspektiven
im liefern kann die forensische
psychiatrie dazu beitragen das böse böse
zu verstehen
in forensische psychiatrie betrachtet
menschen natürlich als individuum mit
mit ihrer persönlichkeitsentwicklung mit
ihrer persönlichkeitsstruktur
vor dem hintergrund möglicher
psychischer erkrankungen die das erleben
und verhalten eines menschen der grund
liegen zu beeinträchtigen können und wir
untersuchen die wechselwirkung zwischen
kriminalität straftaten schweren
verhaltensauffälligkeiten und eben
psychischer gesundheit respektive
psychische erkrankungen also insofern
wie immer von individual- täter aus und
schauen dass es für mensch was macht ihn
aus welche ressourcen hatte welche
einschränkungen geworden
jetzt haben wir neue fälle von
terrorismus die unser denken über das
böse bestimmen
inwiefern kann die forensische
psychiatrie auskünfte über das denken
oder die pathologie von terroristen
geben die sagten in ihrem vortrag vorhin
das sind besonders moralische menschen
die moralität überstrapazieren könnte
das noch ein bisschen erklären
ja also zunächst mal ist natürlich
terrorismus ein politisches problem und
ein gesellschaftliches und kein
medizinisches also wenn man zum beispiel
bei terroristen fragte das werde ich
häufig gefragt sind die denn nicht alle
irre wenn man sich sagen
im engeren sinne sind die nicht sondern
es ist ein sehr komplexes problem aber
wie er in der forensischen psychiatrie
gucken uns auch da wieder sozusagen den
anderen täter an und schauen wie es an
normen und werte gefüge wie sind seine
inneren freiheiten wie es aber mit moral
sie ist sein denken seine denkstruktur
wie sind seine kognitiven überzeugungen
seine legitimation strategien wie ist
seine empathiefähigkeit wie ist seine
fähigkeit der affekt regulation der
impulskontrolle und insofern beschreiben
die auch da wieder den individuellen
täter was bei extremistischen
entwicklungen eine rolle spielt und das
war vielleicht auch der provokante satz
mit der moral ist immer wieder dass wenn
sie terroristische attentäter fragen
dann behaupten wie dass sie auf einer
besonders hypo moralischen seite kämpfen
das ist auch nicht neu das findet man
schon in der französischen revolution
wäre auch etwas na ja der tugendterror
das heißt extremistische gruppen
definieren eine absolute moral sondern
sehr individuelle definition aber es ist
eine absolute moral die sie über allem
anderen stellen und im außen in der
außenwelt werde jetzt sozusagen alle
anderen als schädigende einflüsse als
gsh nutzer dieser hehren moral definiert
und um diese hehre moral über die welt
zu bringen bedarf es einer auslöschung
des anderen und das ist sozusagen ein
rigides 1
man möchte für sun sadistisches moral
verständnis glaube man kann das drogba
waren islamistischen terrorismus ganz
schön sehen dass es da eine enge
verbindung zwischen realität und und
über moralität gibt und dass wenn man
von dieser moralischen seite durch wurde
seitlich moral generalistischen seite
startet dann kippt das ganze
letztendlich in richtung kiefer
amoralität um in richtung logistischer
tag
inwiefern könnte man sagen dass sich
terroristen und extremisten selbst
täuschen ist es so einen psychologischen
mechanismus der rationalen
selbsttäuschung könnte man es so
beschreiben dass man sich etwas ein
weltbild konstruiert in dem die eigenen
absichten plötzlich als gerechtfertigt
erscheinen das kann man sich ja
sozusagen ein anderer punkt ist
natürlich auch daran die selbst
stabilisierung da spielen sicher auch
soziologische theorie eine rolle auf die
marginalisierung werde auch die frage
der integration und jetzt das gespiegelt
seien durch die mehrheitsgesellschaft
und wenn ich subjektiv dena lokale ich
bin in irgendeiner weise benachteiligt
dann kann es natürlich sein dass ich
mich zu einer ideologie finde die mir
eigentlich die moralischen überlegenheit
vermittelt und dass ich in dieser
speziellen viertel eine funktion und
eine bedeutung und wichtigkeit bekomme
und angenommen werde
in einer weise ist mir die andere werks
gesellschaft offenbar versagt oder wie
es mir nicht möglich ist vielleicht ist
das noch besser gesagt wie es mir nicht
möglich ist mich in dieser ordnung
mehrheitsgesellschaft einzufinden
das ist ja nicht nur ein versagen von
außen das ist ja auch so dass man regeln
und codes wir kennen muss um sich
entsprechend beteiligen zu können und
wenn ich diese beteiligung ablehnung
oder sie mir nicht gelingt kann ich mich
sozusagen eine gegenwelt entsprechend
positionieren und darüber einsetzt wird
auch stärken eine letzte frage inwiefern
könnte man sagen dass es grenzen der
zurechenbarkeit gibt jetzt aus so
rettete sich der forensischen
psychiatrie
woran kann man erkennen dass dieser
täter diese person nicht zu rechnen da
ist was muss da vorliegen also vom nicht
zurechenbaren im sinn von schuldunfähig
da sind wir im grunde im bereich der
schizophrene psychosen also da sind wir
im bereich von krankheitsbildern wo die
wahrnehmung der realität so weit eigen
bezüglich ist und so weit von den realen
sachverhalten entfernt hat das sie
bezahlen ist dass die kritische
reflexionsfähigkeit nicht mehr da ist
menschen mit einem schuss zufrieden
waren dem können sie nicht sagen das ist
ein wagen der bahn ist falsch
er kann nicht selber sich daraus
zurücklehnen und sagen na ja wenn ich
jetzt von außen betrachten sie es auch
sondern für den ist das sozusagen
apriori evident und ist darin gefangen
er kann sozusagen nicht mehr frei wählen
also da sind wir im bereich der der
wirklich klassisch nützliche erkrankung
muss ich auch wieder ein guter bezug zur
philosophie gibt sie hatten den begriff
der freiheit erwähnt da sieht man wieder
dass philosophie und forensische
psychiatrie durchaus auch
berührungspunkte haben
vielen dank nochmal für die gespräche
die sehen uns bei der nächsten sendung
von 4cast ja